This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. For the most part, I try to spend as little time as possible in airports. They are loud and crowded and littered with the crumbs of way too many blueberry muffins and chicken Caesar wraps. But I will say that I have one very positive airport memory from my childhood. I grew up mostly in Ohio, and every year I would travel by myself to visit my aunt in Memphis, Tennessee. and to get there, I would always fly through Chicago. And at the O'Hare Airport in Terminal 1, there is this tunnel that connects concourses B and C. When I stepped into this tunnel, it was like I entered a wormhole into another universe.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。在大多数情况下，我尽量减少在机场停留的时间。机场里嘈杂、拥挤，到处都是吃剩的蓝莓松饼和鸡肉凯撒卷的碎屑。但我不得不说，我童年时期对机场有一个非常美好的记忆。我大部分时间是在俄亥俄州长大的，每年我都会独自一人去田纳西州的孟菲斯探望我的姑姑。为了到达那里，我总是经由芝加哥转机。在奥黑尔机场的1号航站楼，有一条连接B和C登机口的隧道。当我走进这条隧道时，感觉就像进入了一个通往另一个宇宙的虫洞。
I was surrounded on all sides by a mosaic of pulsing neon lights. George Gershwin's Rhapsody in Blue was playing. It was transportive and calming, and I loved it. I think it was one of the first moments in my life where I actively appreciated the design of a space. I also have a weirdly meaningful attachment to this tunnel. I was born in Chicago. My family still lives half an hour from O'Hare.
我被四周闪烁的霓虹灯马赛克所包围。乔治·格什温的《蓝色狂想曲》正在播放。它让人仿佛置身他处，心旷神怡，我非常喜欢。我想这是我人生中第一次主动欣赏一个空间的建筑设计。我对这条隧道也有着一种奇怪而深刻的依恋。我出生在芝加哥。我的家人至今仍住在离奥黑尔机场半小时路程的地方。
That is reporter Jasper Davidoff. And for me, what really makes this tunnel of light so special and otherworldly is that as you travel through it, the ground beneath your feet is moving. All right, here we go. When you go down the escalator into the tunnel, you step onto a metal conveyor belt. And from there, you float through this mystical, colorful portal on the way to your gate. And I'm starting to hear the opening sounds of Rhapsody and blue. Oh, my God.
那是记者贾斯珀·达维多夫。对我来说，这条光之隧道之所以如此特别且超凡脱俗，是因为当你穿过它时，脚下的地面在移动。好了，我们出发吧。当你走下自动扶梯进入隧道时，你会踏上一条金属传送带。从那里开始，你将漂浮着穿过这个神秘而多彩的门户，前往你的登机口。我开始听到《蓝色狂想曲》的开场旋律了。天哪。
And the lights, they're just flashing above me. Even if you've never flown through O'Hare, The odds are pretty good that you've experienced this feeling of drifting slowly through a concourse with your suitcase. Because the tunnel of light is a dramatic setting for a pretty common piece of airport infrastructure, the moving walkway. Moving walkways, or people movers, as they're sometimes called, can be found in most major American airports. And at least in theory, they serve a pretty important function, moving a bunch of very rushed people, very short distances, a little quicker than they can on their own two feet. But the thing about moving walkways is that you pretty much only see them at the airport,
灯光就在我头顶闪烁。即使你从未飞经奥黑尔机场，你也很有可能体验过这种拖着行李箱在航站楼里缓慢漂流的感觉。因为这条光之隧道为一种非常常见的机场基础设施——自动人行道——提供了一个戏剧性的背景。自动人行道，有时也被称为“旅客捷运系统”，在大多数美国大型机场都能见到。至少在理论上，它们发挥着相当重要的作用，能让一群行色匆匆的人以比步行稍快的速度走过很短的距离。但自动人行道的问题在于，你几乎只在机场才能见到它们，
which got me thinking, like, what is the deal with these things? How did they get to be so ubiquitous in airports and basically nowhere else? And it turns out, they were not invented to get you to your plane on time. The moving walkway was originally seen as a form of mass transportation. Over the course of a century, a group of architects and engineers dreamed of turning the sidewalk into a magic carpet that could carry people all throughout the city. And that dream began in New York. In the mid-1800s, there were basically only two ways to get around Manhattan. You could take a horse-drawn carriage, or you could walk.
这让我开始思考，这些东西到底是怎么回事？它们是如何在机场变得如此普遍，而在其他地方却几乎绝迹的？事实证明，它们的发明初衷并不是为了让你准时赶上飞机。自动人行道最初被视为一种大众交通工具。在一个世纪的时间里，一群建筑师和工程师梦想着将人行道变成一条可以载着人们穿梭于整个城市的“魔毯”。而这个梦想始于纽约。在19世纪中期，曼哈顿的出行方式基本上只有两种：你可以乘坐马车，或者步行。
The first form of public transportation in New York was called the omnibus. It was a carriage that could fit about 12 people, if they were. they squeezed. For 12 cents, you could get a bumpy, nauseating ride from one address below 14th street to another address below 14th Street. And without any real mass transit, the streets were crowded and chaotic. Specifically in New York and other larger cities, there was a recognition that they needed better ways for people to get around. This is Lee Gray, an architectural historian and Professor Emeritus at UNC Charlotte. And I am a recognizing. expert in the history of vertical transportation and occasionally horizontal transportation,
纽约第一种公共交通工具被称为“公共马车”（omnibus）。那是一辆如果挤一挤，大约能容纳12人的马车。花12美分，你就能在14街以下的一个地址到另一个地址之间，体验一段颠簸且令人作呕的旅程。由于没有任何真正的大众交通系统，街道上拥挤而混乱。特别是在纽约和其他大城市，人们意识到他们需要更好的出行方式。这位是李·格雷，一位建筑历史学家和北卡罗来纳大学夏洛特分校的荣誉退休教授。我是一位公认的垂直交通历史专家，偶尔也研究水平交通，
if it has in reference to buildings. So as elevators, escalators, and moving sidewalks. This is my kind of guy. How can I spend an entire academic career studying elevators and, you know, the sort of fascination they hold for me, you know, why do I do this? I don't know. Lee says that it was in crowded Manhattan that an inventor had an idea to completely change how people move about the city.
如果它与建筑有关的话。比如电梯、自动扶梯和自动人行道。这正是我的研究领域。我怎么能用整个学术生涯来研究电梯，你知道，它们对我有着某种吸引力，你知道，我为什么要这样做？我不知道。李说，正是在拥挤的曼哈顿，一位发明家萌生了一个彻底改变人们在城市中移动方式的想法。
His name was Alfred Speer. No relation to Nazi architect Albert Speer, just to clear that up. Alfred Speer is not so infamous. In fact, he's not very well known at all. Most people have no clue who he was. If he compiled it together and presented it properly, you could do one hell of an HBO documentary on the man. This is Mark Auerbach, a local historian from Speer's hometown of Passaic, New Jersey.
他的名字叫阿尔弗雷德·斯皮尔。为了澄清一下，他与纳粹建筑师阿尔伯特·斯皮尔没有任何关系。阿尔弗雷德·斯皮尔并不那么臭名昭著。事实上，他一点也不出名。大多数人根本不知道他是谁。如果有人能把他的一切整理出来并妥善呈现，完全可以为这个人拍一部精彩的HBO纪录片。这是马克·奥尔巴赫，来自斯皮尔家乡新泽西州帕塞伊克的当地历史学家。
Rizzie. Mark says that Alfred Speer was a man of many talents. He was a street superintendent, a city planner of sorts. But he was also a carpenter and an inventor. I guess he liked creating things and making things and always looking at things and how can he improve it. Anything and everything was fair game for him. If he saw a problem and his, you know, his mind was always working. What can he do better? Speer's primary job was running a wine business that had a store in Lower Manhattan. And one morning in 1871, he stepped outside of his wine shop and looked at the gobs of people packing the streets, and he said to himself, we got to do something about this. And so Speer did what he did best. He started tinkering. So 1871, Alfred Spear proposed, he called it an endless traveling sidewalk system that would have taken people up and down the length of Broadway.
里齐。马克说，阿尔弗雷德·斯皮尔是一个多才多艺的人。他曾是一名街道主管，算是一位城市规划师。但他也是一名木匠和发明家。我想他喜欢创造和制造东西，总是观察事物并思考如何改进它们。任何事物对他来说都是改进的对象。如果他发现了一个问题，他的大脑总是在运转。他能做得更好吗？斯皮尔的主要工作是经营一家在曼哈顿下城有门店的葡萄酒生意。1871年的一天早上，他走出酒铺，看着街道上挤满的人群，对自己说，我们必须为此做点什么。于是，斯皮尔做了他最擅长的事。他开始修修补补。所以1871年，阿尔弗雷德·斯皮尔提出了一个方案，他称之为“无尽移动人行道系统”，可以让人们沿着百老汇大街上下往返。
And it would have run above the regular. Gitter sidewalk. It would have been mounted on sort of stanchions and you would ascend a flight of steps and you would step onto the moving sidewalk. Basically, picture a platform at about the second floor of the nearby buildings with two parallel sidewalks, one fixed and one moving. The moving sidewalk would be 18 feet wide and be in constant motion. That way, people could step on and off whenever they pleased. There would be some benches on there and some awnings for a bit of shelter, Along the side, there would be drawing rooms and smoking rooms every now and then. There would be stairs coming up to the moving sidewalk from the street,
它将运行在普通的人行道之上。它将安装在某种支柱上，你走上一段台阶，然后踏上移动人行道。基本上，想象一个位于附近建筑物二楼高度的平台，有两条平行的通道，一条固定，一条移动。移动人行道将有18英尺宽，并保持持续运动。这样，人们可以随时随地上下。上面会有一些长椅和遮阳棚供人遮蔽，沿途还会不时出现休息室和吸烟室。会有楼梯从街道通向移动人行道，
or business owners could simply build a bridge from their establishments to the platform level. And it would take you along, and then you could hop off a light from the moving sidewalk, and go in and get a glass of lemonade or coffee or whatever, and then get back on the moving sidewalk. And it was this very easy and elegant way to travel along. This was around the same time that the first elevated trains were going up in New York City, and the moving sidewalk was seen as an alternative transit strategy. It would be like the train that never stopped.
或者店主可以直接从他们的店铺建一座桥通往平台层。它会带着你前行，然后你可以从移动人行道上跳下来，进去喝杯柠檬水或咖啡什么的，然后再回到移动人行道上。这是一种非常简单而优雅的旅行方式。这大约是在纽约市第一批高架火车建成的时候，移动人行道被视为一种替代性的交通策略。它就像一列永不停歇的火车。
To quote Spear, it would be an endless train that would appeal to a uniquely American sense of impatience. And so that's also the attraction. I don't have to wait. I jump on the moving sidewalk and it takes me there. You can walk down into a station, immediately get on board, and go. Speer's plan shifted over the couple years that he developed the idea, but by the time he officially proposed it to the city of New York, he wanted the sidewalk to be moving at 10 miles an hour. That might sound slow compared to a car, but if you think in terms of a treadmill, it's dangerously quick. And so to prevent New Yorkers from falling flat on their face, Speer imagined a whole system of transfer stations, basically moving platforms that would help pedestrians get up to speed.
引用斯皮尔的话，它将是一列“无尽的火车”，能够迎合美国人特有的不耐烦心理。所以这也是它的吸引力所在。我不必等待。我跳上移动人行道，它就会带我到达目的地。你可以走进车站，立即上车，然后出发。斯皮尔的计划在他构思的几年里有所调整，但当他正式向纽约市提出时，他希望人行道能以每小时10英里的速度移动。这与汽车相比可能听起来很慢，但如果你从跑步机的角度来想，这可是危险的快。因此，为了防止纽约人摔个狗吃屎，斯皮尔设想了一整套换乘站系统，基本上就是移动平台，可以帮助行人加速。
At 10 miles an hour, Speer calculated his invention would be capable of transporting 18,000 passengers every hour all day long. Speer was insistent that this was the only way to solve the city's congestion problem. In a report he submitted to the state government about the proposal, he wrote, in all caps, it is the solution and the only true solution of rapid transit. And in 1871, he filed his first two patents for, quote, an endless train for rapid through transit of passengers without stops. Influential businessman that he was, Speer managed to get quite far convincing local leaders
斯皮尔计算出，以每小时10英里的速度，他的发明每天每小时能够运送18,000名乘客。斯皮尔坚持认为这是解决城市拥堵问题的唯一途径。在提交给州政府的关于该提案的报告中，他用全大写字母写道：“它是解决快速交通的方案，也是唯一真正的方案。”1871年，他为“一种用于乘客快速通过且无需停靠的无尽火车”申请了他的前两项专利。作为一名有影响力的商人，斯皮尔设法说服了当地领导人，
that a moving sidewalk was the best plan for Manhattan. In fact, he got the New York State Legislature to pass two bills supporting the endless train. Well, yeah, two administrations in a row, 1873, 1874, supported it based upon the fact that he was granted a patent. Do you think this is, like, people generally would have taken this seriously? Absolutely. You don't get a patent on something it's whimsical.
移动人行道是曼哈顿的最佳方案。事实上，他让纽约州议会通过了两项支持“无尽火车”的法案。嗯，是的，连续两届政府，1873年和1874年，都基于他获得了专利这一事实给予了支持。你认为人们通常会认真对待这件事吗？当然。你不会给异想天开的东西申请专利。
And who knows, maybe Spears' Moving Sidewalk could have become as integral to Manhattan as Central Park or, I don't know, Times Square Elmo. But it never got built. Because both times New York Governor John Dix vetoed the measures. Reports vary over why, but. In addition to the cost, it said the governor wasn't a big fan of the fact that the sidewalk would be looming over Broadway twice, once in each direction. After the veto, Speer mostly gave up on his transportation dreams to focus on his wine business. But his idea of a moving sidewalk was out in the world. And pretty soon, it took on a life of its own.
谁知道呢，也许斯皮尔的移动人行道本可以像中央公园或时代广场的艾尔莫一样成为曼哈顿不可或缺的一部分。但它从未建成。因为纽约州州长约翰·迪克斯两次否决了这些措施。关于原因的报道各不相同，但除了成本之外，据说州长不太喜欢人行道会两次悬在百老汇上空（每个方向一次）的事实。否决后，斯皮尔基本上放弃了他的交通梦想，转而专注于他的葡萄酒生意。但他的移动人行道理念已经传开了。很快，它就有了自己的生命。
In the following decades, there were more moving sidewalk proposals in cities throughout Europe. And then, in 1893 at the Chicago World's Fair, they actually built one out on a pier into Lake Michigan. And you paid a fee and you could ride out on the moving sidewalk, out at the end of the pier, see the lake, and it would curve around, and it would bring you back. So instead of transportation system, it was kind of an amusement ride, sort of. But it was the 1900 World's Fair in Paris, where Spears' idea was most fully realized. A pretty amazing technological feat for the time, so it was about four kilometers long, a full circle, in the city of Paris, pretty much in the center.
在接下来的几十年里，欧洲各地的城市出现了更多的移动人行道提案。然后，在1893年的芝加哥世博会上，他们真的在伸入密歇根湖的码头上建造了一条。你付了钱就可以坐上移动人行道，一直到码头尽头，看看湖景，它会转弯，然后把你带回来。所以与其说它是交通系统，不如说它是一种游乐设施。但正是在1900年的巴黎世博会上，斯皮尔的想法得到了最充分的实现。这对当时来说是一项相当了不起的技术成就，它全长约四公里，在巴黎市中心绕了一个完整的圆圈。
That's Erci Hottimo, a media archaeologist at UCLA. And he says it was called Le Trotroix-Roulon, the moving walkway. Yeah, so the Trotter-Roulon in Paris was quite a special one. So it was built above the sort of like ground level. And it had two mobile platform, the high-speed one, and the sort of like a little bit slower speed one. And then it had stationary platform. So basically three options.
那是加州大学洛杉矶分校的媒体考古学家埃尔西·霍蒂莫。他说它被称为“Le Trottoir Roulant”，即移动人行道。是的，巴黎的“Trottoir Roulant”非常特别。它建在地面之上。它有两个移动平台，一个是高速的，一个是稍微慢一点的。然后还有一个固定平台。所以基本上有三种选择。
This walkway was designed to help people traverse the fairgrounds, connecting the long distances between the pavilions. So in that sense, I mean, it definitely had a practical function. But very soon it was clear. that this was much more than that. It was really an attraction in its own ride. So it's something that people had never experienced anywhere. Paris's moving walkway was bigger and bolder than anything anyone had seen before.
这条人行道旨在帮助人们穿过展区，连接各个展馆之间的长距离。所以从这个意义上说，它绝对具有实际功能。但很快人们就清楚了，这远不止于此。它本身就是一种吸引力。这是人们在任何地方都从未体验过的。巴黎的移动人行道比任何人以前见过的都要宏大、大胆。
Of the course of about 25 minutes, the walkway would carry passengers through the city center traversing the footprint of the fair. This was not an amusement park ride relegated to a pier. It was in your face. At certain points, quite literally. In some places, the Dirtua Ruland ran along boulevards, and because it was on a higher level on a platform, so it ended up being in front of people's windows.
在大约25分钟的时间里，人行道载着乘客穿过市中心，横跨整个博览会的占地范围。这不再是一个被降级到码头的游乐园设施。它就在你面前。在某些地方，简直是近在咫尺。在某些路段，“Trottoir Roulant”沿着林荫大道运行，因为它位于较高的平台上，所以最终出现在人们的窗前。
Some people were really shocked about the idea, thought that their privacy was being basically, like, violated. But some forward-thinking entrepreneurs tried to take advantage of this new stream of potential customers. There were stories that, for example, the public ladies were selling or trying to sell their services in some of the windows that this platform passed. The trotoir was something of an engineering marvel. The whole thing ran on electric motors at a time when electric infrastructure was not widespread. So the organizers of the World's Fair had to build their own power station on the grounds and then keep the whole thing
有些人对这个想法感到非常震惊，认为他们的隐私基本上受到了侵犯。但一些有远见的企业家试图利用这一新的潜在客户流。有故事说，例如，公共场所的女士们在平台经过的一些窗户里兜售或试图兜售她们的服务。这条人行道堪称工程奇迹。整个系统依靠电动机运行，而在当时电力基础设施并不普及。因此，世博会的组织者不得不自己在场地上建造发电站，然后让整个系统
running continuously for several months. Some of the earliest surviving silent film is of people riding the Paris moving walkway. Thomas Edison's film company was actually there documenting the whole thing. They placed a camera on the walkway and let it roll. Watching the film, you see this mass of wood and electricity gliding through central Paris. You see the ornate apartments and grand festival buildings go by. And you can really imagine the sheer thrill it would have been to take this ride.
连续运行了几个月。一些现存最早的无声电影就是人们乘坐巴黎移动人行道的画面。托马斯·爱迪生的电影公司当时就在现场记录这一切。他们把摄像机放在人行道上，让它转动。看着电影，你会看到这团木头和电力在巴黎市中心滑行。你看到华丽的公寓和宏伟的节日建筑掠过。你真的可以想象乘坐这种交通工具会是多么令人兴奋。
Especially if it was one of the first times you had experienced electric power. There's one moment where an older man and woman hopped down from the lower speed platform, each grabbing one of the poles that were attached for balance. And the woman has this goofy little expression on her face. Like, did I really just get off a sidewalk moving two miles an hour? The Chautau-Roulin in Paris finally brought Alfred Spears' dream to life and showed that it was actually possible to build a moving walkway inside a major city. But it was still a temporary attraction connected to a world's fair.
特别是如果这是你第一次体验电力的话。有一个瞬间，一位年长的男人和女人从低速平台上跳下来，每人抓住一根用来保持平衡的杆子。那个女人的脸上带着一种滑稽的小表情。就像是，我真的刚从一条以每小时两英里速度移动的人行道上下来吗？巴黎的“Trottoir Roulant”终于让阿尔弗雷德·斯皮尔的梦想成真，并证明了在主要城市内建造移动人行道确实是可能的。但它仍然是一个与世博会相连的临时景点。
If the technology was going to take off in a meaningful way, there would need to be a permanent walkway that served a practical transportation function. And for a second, it looked like a moving walkway might get installed in an extremely practical place, a bridge that connected Brooklyn to Manhattan, one that more than 300,000 people used every day. I mean, the Brooklyn Bridge, this is one of the most, you know, soon the minute it's completed is one of the most famous bridges in the world. In 1902, New York's Commissioner of Bridges, Gustav Lindenthal, came up with a plan to
如果这项技术要以有意义的方式起飞，就需要一条能够发挥实际交通功能的永久性人行道。有一瞬间，看起来移动人行道可能会安装在一个极其务实的地方：连接布鲁克林和曼哈顿的桥梁，每天有超过30万人使用。我的意思是，布鲁克林大桥，这是世界上最著名的桥梁之一。1902年，纽约桥梁专员古斯塔夫·林登塔尔提出了一个计划，
build a moving walkway that could whisk commuters over the East River at 10 miles an hour. But he didn't get very far. The New York Times called the bridge plan magnificently impractical. And government officials couldn't seem to get over the moving walkway's amusement park reputation. But the most powerful argument against this moving walkway was that the Brooklyn Bridge already had a train. By this point, cable cars have been crossing the bridge for nearly 20 years. And as the subway expanded in the early 20th century, it became clear that the train was now New York's transatlantic. mode of choice, which made people ask, what was the moving sidewalk even for?
建造一条移动人行道，能以每小时10英里的速度将通勤者送过东河。但他没能走多远。《纽约时报》称该桥梁计划“宏伟而不切实际”。政府官员似乎无法克服移动人行道“游乐园设施”的名声。但反对这条移动人行道最有力的论据是，布鲁克林大桥已经有了火车。到那时，缆车已经跨越这座桥近20年了。随着20世纪初地铁的扩张，很明显火车已成为纽约首选的跨河交通方式，这让人们不禁要问，移动人行道到底有什么用？
But true believers were undeterred. They kept building demo versions of a moving sidewalk to try and convince skeptical transportation officials. What tended to happen at those large models is city officials would show up, they would ride around, they would say, wow, that was really cool. We'll think about this, and then the next day go, you know, we're not really interested, sorry. It was a pattern And sometimes they would even be wildly enthusiastic about it And then when it would come to vote on it They would just say, well, it's a little, it's a bridge too far
但真正的信徒并没有被吓倒。他们不断建造移动人行道的演示版本，试图说服持怀疑态度的交通官员。在那些大型模型上往往会发生这样的情况：城市官员会出现，他们会四处转转，他们会说，哇，这真的很酷。我们会考虑一下，然后第二天就说，你知道，我们真的不感兴趣，抱歉。这是一种模式。有时他们甚至会对此表现出极大的热情，但当真正要投票表决时，他们只会说，嗯，这有点太超前了。
We just can't do it And the dream of turning sidewalks into conveyor belts Might have just died there Were it not for a new champion who picked up the baton Unlike the previous moving walkway supporters These guys were not motivated by utopian transportation dreams but instead by the desire to sell a lot of rubber. Good Year, tires are still our main business,
我们就是做不到。而将人行道变成传送带的梦想可能就此破灭了，如果不是因为一位接过接力棒的新拥护者出现的话。与之前的移动人行道支持者不同，这些人不是出于乌托邦式的交通梦想，而是出于销售大量橡胶的愿望。固特异，轮胎仍然是我们的主要业务，
but from the original products have come thousands of new lines, new ways to serve people. During World War II, the Goodyear Tire Company received a bunch of military contracts that allowed them to open new factories across North America. After the war, they started looking to create new ways to sell their product, and one of their ideas was conveyor belts. These moving belts can do so many useful things. Miles long, they carry great tonnages of bulk materials. Belts can carry people, too, in many ways, many places.
但从最初的产品中衍生出了成千上万的新系列，服务人们的新方式。二战期间，固特异轮胎公司获得了大量军事合同，使他们能够在北美各地开设新工厂。战后，他们开始寻找销售产品的新方法，他们的想法之一就是传送带。这些移动带可以做很多有用的事情。长达数英里，它们运送大量的散装材料。传送带也可以载人，在很多方面，很多地方。
Good Year went out looking for places where they could try out their human conveyor belt technology, and eventually they landed on a train station in Jersey City. There was a long tunnel with a steep grade that riders had to traverse to get to the train. And the Stevens-Adamson manufacturing company, in association with Goodyear, built two moving walkways side by side to carry passengers up and down that incline to and from the train. And it was wildly successful. Ironically, the moving walkway succeeded not as an alternative to the train, but as a way to make train travel better. The train would get you where you needed to go, but the moving walkway would get you to the train. By the 1950s, the dream of an entire city connected by moving sidewalks had gone by the wayside.
固特异开始寻找可以试验其人类传送带技术的地方，最终他们看中了泽西城的一个火车站。那里有一条带有陡坡的长隧道，乘客必须穿过它才能到达火车。史蒂文斯-亚当森制造公司与固特异合作，并排建造了两条移动人行道，将乘客运送上坡或下坡，往返于火车。它非常成功。具有讽刺意味的是，移动人行道之所以成功，并不是作为火车的替代品，而是作为让火车旅行变得更好的方式。火车能把你带到你需要去的地方，但移动人行道能把你带到火车上。到了20世纪50年代，整个城市由移动人行道连接的梦想已经破灭。
But letting go of that lofty vision actually allowed the technology to succeed. And the moving walkway started to catch on in smaller settings like train stations, museums, and stadiums. When the Sam Houston Coliseum in Texas was renovated in 1956, it got a moment. moving walkway. When the Travelator Motel opened in San Diego in 1959, the pedestrian bridge built by its owner got a moving walkway. One of the first car washes in California put in a moving walkway so you could glide alongside your car as it got cleaned. But the moving walkway ultimately found its perfect use case in an up-and-coming institution, the airport. Many of the first modern American airports were built in the 30s and 40s.
但放弃那个崇高的愿景实际上让这项技术得以成功。移动人行道开始在火车站、博物馆和体育场等较小的环境中流行起来。当德克萨斯州的萨姆·休斯顿体育馆在1956年翻新时，它安装了一条移动人行道。当圣地亚哥的Travelator汽车旅馆在1959年开业时，其业主建造的人行天桥也安装了一条移动人行道。加州最早的洗车店之一安装了一条移动人行道，这样你就可以在车被清洗时滑行在车旁。但移动人行道最终在一个新兴机构——机场——找到了完美的用例。许多美国最早的现代机场建于30年代和40年代。
But with the introduction of airliners and then jet planes like the 707, commercial air travel got exponentially more popular. And by 1950, airlines in the U.S. were carrying 13 times the passengers that they had in 1938. The country's fledgling airports were not prepared for this boom, and very quickly they needed to expand. You couldn't stack airplanes vertically. So airports sprawled outward. And that meant a lot more walking. It demanded more of these horizontal kind of connective devices, you know. Yeah, in some cases, they were at something like five football fields, you know.
但随着客机和波音707等喷气式飞机的引入，商业航空旅行变得越来越受欢迎。到1950年，美国航空公司的客运量是1938年的13倍。该国初出茅庐的机场没有为这种繁荣做好准备，很快它们就需要扩张。你不能垂直堆叠飞机。所以机场向外蔓延。这意味着要走更多的路。它需要更多这种水平连接设备，你知道。是的，在某些情况下，它们相当于五个足球场那么长，你知道。
I think that's Chicago O'Hare. You know, if you were unlucky to come in on one airline had to shift quickly to another, you know, you had this incredible trek. you had to make. Alistair Gordon is a journalist and critic, whose book, Naked Airport, chronicles the evolution of aviation infrastructure. He says that O'Hare actually became known as Cardiac Alley because of the epic journey that passengers had to take to get from check-in to boarding.
我想那是芝加哥奥黑尔机场。你知道，如果你不幸乘坐一家航空公司的航班到达，又必须迅速转乘另一家，你知道，你必须经历这段不可思议的跋涉。阿利斯泰尔·戈登是一位记者和评论家，他的书《裸体机场》记录了航空基础设施的演变。他说，奥黑尔机场实际上被称为“心脏病小巷”，因为乘客从办理登机手续到登机必须经历史诗般的旅程。
This story repeated over and over, and in the span of just a few decades, people began to dread their trips to the airport. John Updike talks about this rink. bat's passage, you know, from, you know, the parking lot to the actual airplane. Even Kafka wrote about an airport and, you know, kind of was alienated by the whole thing. As you can imagine, Kafka would be. So when you say, you know, airports are Kafka-esque, you know, he really actually did go to an airport and have some kind of depressive, you know, moment.
这个故事一遍又一遍地重复，在短短几十年内，人们开始害怕去机场。约翰·厄普代克谈到了这种从停车场到飞机的旅程。甚至卡夫卡也写过关于机场的事情，你知道，被整个事情疏远了。正如你可以想象的那样，卡夫卡会这样。所以当你提到，你知道，机场是卡夫卡式的，你知道，他确实去过机场，并有过某种抑郁的时刻。
If only, the airlines lamented, there were some way to ensure that getting to your plane would not require an interminable, uncomfortable slog. And this is where the moving walkway, this actually quite old idea, finally met its moment. In 1958, the Dallas Lovefield Airport installed the very first airport moving walkway. That was the installation that captured the imagination of the American public in a profound way. Everybody included photographs of people riding the moving sidewalk, going out to get on a plane. The dopy little conveyor belt at Lovefield only moved about one and a half miles an hour. But to the public, it was just as sexy as cruising at 10,000 feet.
航空公司感叹，如果有什么方法能确保去飞机的路上不需要经历漫长、不舒服的跋涉就好了。这就是移动人行道，这个实际上相当古老的想法，终于迎来了它的时刻。1958年，达拉斯洛夫菲尔德机场安装了第一个机场移动人行道。那次安装以一种深刻的方式抓住了美国公众的想象力。每个人都拍下了人们乘坐移动人行道去登机的照片。洛夫菲尔德那个笨拙的小传送带每小时只移动约1.5英里。但对公众来说，它和在10,000英尺高空巡航一样性感。
It was all part of the space age appeal of air travel. And apparently people would just come and just ride it back and forth. They weren't going anywhere, but they were fascinated by this futuristic thing. Dallas kicked off a trend that other airports were quick to follow. At LAX, where passengers had to walk for 1,250 feet to get from check-in to their planes, American Airlines started promoting a campaign to take the walking out of flying. They put in a moving sidewalk called The Astro Way, and they came up with a clever idea to market it.
这都是航空旅行太空时代吸引力的一部分。显然，人们会专门过来来回乘坐它。他们哪儿也不去，但他们被这个未来主义的东西迷住了。达拉斯开启了一个其他机场迅速效仿的趋势。在洛杉矶国际机场，乘客必须步行1,250英尺才能从值机柜台到达飞机，美国航空公司开始发起一场“让步行远离飞行”的运动。他们安装了一条名为“天文之路”（The Astro Way）的移动人行道，并想出了一个聪明的营销点子。
It was a throwback to the famous I Love Lucy scene, where Lucy and Ethel are scrambling to deal with a flood of chocolate bonbons rushing to them on a conveyor belt and wrapping them up and shoving them frantically in their mouths. They got Lucille Ball herself to come ride the Astro Way and show that it was safe and fun.
这是对著名的《我爱露西》场景的致敬，露西和埃塞尔正忙着处理传送带上涌来的一大堆巧克力糖果，她们疯狂地包装并把它们塞进嘴里。他们请来了露西尔·鲍尔本人来乘坐“天文之路”，以证明它是安全有趣的。
I got some great publicity photographs from this woman in American Airlines at LAX who had it's incredible. material, just in her desk. And it was these photographs of Lucille Ball who had been hired just to show, mainly to show women that you could ride on this Astro Way, moving sidewalk at LAX,
我从洛杉矶国际机场的一位美国航空公司女士那里得到了一些很棒的宣传照片，她桌子里有令人难以置信的材料。那是露西尔·鲍尔的照片，她被雇来主要是为了向女性展示你可以乘坐洛杉矶国际机场的“天文之路”移动人行道，
that you could even, even with high heels on, you could ride this thing. And there's a great picture of a certain going saying, look, Mom, no hands. Beginning in the 60s and 70s, airports all around the country began installing their own moving walkways. The appeal wasn't just to say,
即使穿着高跟鞋，你也可以乘坐这个东西。有一张很棒的照片，一个孩子说：“看，妈妈，不用手。”从60年代和70年代开始，全国各地的机场都开始安装自己的移动人行道。吸引力不仅仅是为了看起来时髦。带着沉重行李的疲惫乘客很感激有机会休息双腿。对于行动不便的人来说，它们是一个非常有用的设施。但人行道也向机场旅客发出信号，表明这些令人不快的迷宫实际上是现代且高效的。如果有一条人行道最能代表这个想法，那可能就是奥黑尔机场的那条。富有远见的建筑师赫尔穆特·扬在80年代中期设计了奥黑尔机场的新联合航站楼。航站楼由两条长长的平行大厅组成，配有高耸的玻璃天花板。你知道，这里充满了光。这是一个巨大的玻璃拱顶。这个想法让人想起
seem snazzy. Wary passengers with heavy bags appreciated the chance to rest their legs. And for people with mobility issues, they were a really useful accommodation. But the walkways also signaled to airport goers that these unpleasant labyrinths were actually modern and efficient. And if there's a single walkway that best represents that idea, it's probably the one at O'Hare. The visionary architect Helmut Yon designed the new United Terminal at O'Hare in the mid-80s. The terminal consisted of two long parallel concourses with soaring glass ceilings. You know, this was filled with light. It was this great glass vault. This idea is reminiscent of
欧洲伟大的火车站。你知道，这确实是一个开创性的设计。以前没有人见过这样的东西。这是扬建筑事务所的董事总经理菲利普·卡斯蒂略。他说，扬需要考虑的一件事是乘客到达登机口必须经过的这条极长的隧道。他们认识到它需要成为某种东西。它不能只是
the great train stations in Europe. You know, this was really a groundbreaking design. No one had seen anything like this before. This is Philip Castillo, managing director at Jan's architecture firm. And he says that one thing Jan needed to reckon with was this extremely long tunnel that passengers needed to navigate to get to their gate. They recognized it needed to be something. It cannot just be
这条800英尺长的隧道，墙壁是混凝土块或瓷砖，天花板是吊顶。它需要不仅仅是那样。这就是我们得到奥黑尔光之隧道的原因。一个将本可能成为可怕跋涉的设计
this 800 foot long tunnel with concrete block walls or tile and a lay-in ceiling. It needed to be more than that. And that is how we got the O'Hare Tunnel of Light. A design that turned what could have been a horrible slog
变成了我和罗曼小时候都期待的魔毯之旅。菲利普记得他第一次走过完工的隧道时的情景。我觉得它很棒。我甚至喜欢那音乐。我觉得它对这种从A点移动到B点的想法非常深刻，
into a magic carpet ride that both Roman and I looked forward. to his kids. Philip remembers the very first time he walked through the completed tunnel. I thought it was great. I even loved the music. I thought it was really kind of poignant to this kind of idea
我仍然喜欢它。我仍然喜欢去那里。但奥黑尔光之隧道可能是移动人行道作为一种交通技术的巅峰，因为在最近几十年里，旅客捷运系统已经进入了
of how one moves from point A to point B. And I still like it. I still enjoy going down there. But the O'Hare Tunnel of Light may have been the high point for the moving walkway as a piece of transportation technology because in recent decades, the People Mover has gone into
衰退期。是的，奥黑尔机场那条令人着迷的移动人行道还在那里，但它是航站楼里仅存的一条。2015年，联合航空拆除了其他八条移动人行道。全国许多其他机场也发生了同样的情况，包括拉斯维加斯、奥兰多、辛辛那提和旧金山。机场开始不再喜欢移动人行道有几个汇聚的原因。随着设备老化，维修变得越来越困难和昂贵。人们也越来越认识到，这些旅客捷运系统移动人的速度不够快。曾有人尝试让它们跑得更快，但更快通常意味着更多的绊倒和跌倒。所以大多数人行道继续以每小时一到两英里的合理速度缓慢前行。
decline. Yes, the trippy moving walkway at O'Hare is still there, but it's the only one left in the terminal. In 2015, United ripped out all eight of the other moving walkways. The same thing is happening at a lot of other airports around the country, including Las Vegas, Orlando, Cincinnati, and San Francisco. There's a few converging reasons why airports started falling out of love with the moving walkway. As the equipment got older, repairs became harder and more expensive. There's also a growing acknowledgement that these people movers just don't move people quickly enough. There have been attempts to make them go faster, but faster usually means more trips and falls. And so most of them keep chugging along at a reasonable one to two
研究发现，如果周围没有人，在机场使用移动人行道会让你快一点点到达登机口。但如果它们被行人堵塞，因为人们不遵守正确的礼仪站在右侧，它们实际上会让你变慢。我们凭直觉都知道这一点。如果你赶不上航班，正急着在登机门关闭前赶到，你是会冒着被堵在移动人行道上的风险，还是直接跑过去？但从根本上说，我认为我们看到移动人行道减少的最大原因只是机场已经改变了。随着安检的加强，乘客往往会很早就到达机场。然后他们基本上被困在航站楼里，无事可做。
miles per hour. Studies find that using the moving walkway at an airport will get you to your gate a tiny bit faster if there's no one around. But if they get clogged up with pedestrians, because people aren't following proper etiquette and standing on the right, they can actually slow you down. And we all kind of know this intuitively. If you're late to your flight and you're rushing to make it before the doors close, are you going to risk getting jammed up on the moving walkway or just run for it? But fundamentally, I think the biggest reason that we're seeing fewer moving walkways is just that airports have changed. With increased security, passengers tend to get to the airport really early. And then they're essentially trapped in the terminal with nothing to do.
机场不再是一个尽可能快地穿过的地方。它是一个像商场一样闲逛的地方。今天的机场，在某种程度上，它们有点像购物中心。你知道，你在那里确实是一个被俘获的观众，因为你在等飞机，你必须做点什么。所以为什么不购物呢？如果你从哈德逊新闻店逛到书店，你真的不需要移动人行道。我想在过去五年里它们都被拆除了，因为购物或吃饭的概念更多地成为了机场体验的一部分。但对于每一条关于移动人行道因为过时、缓慢或占用太多空间而注定失败的批评，对我来说，另一件事仍然是真的，那就是它们很棒。它们是快乐的机器，只要一分钟，就能让你沉浸在我们现代世界运动部件的交响乐中。如果你回顾历史上所有成功的移动人行道，它们在很大程度上之所以成功，不是因为它们高效，而是因为人们真心喜欢乘坐它们。所以即使我因为乘坐移动人行道损失了30秒，你也会看到我站在上面，站在右侧让其他乘客通过。
The airport is no longer a place to move through as quickly as possible. It's a place to hang out, like a mall. Airports today, they're to some extent, they're kind of like shopping centers. You know, you're really a captive audience in there because you're waiting for your plane and you have to do something. So why not shop? And you don't really need a moving walkway if you're wandering from the Hudson News to the storebox. I think in the last five years they've all been removed because this concept of shopping or eating is much more part of the airport experience. But for every critique about how
好了，这是旅程中最后一条移动人行道，我已经踏上去了。行李员肯定在笑我，但没关系，因为我玩得很开心，所以我也在笑。移动人行道即将结束，请向下看。休息后回来，我们有一些移动人行道科幻小说。好了，我们回来了，我和报道那个故事的贾斯珀·达维多夫在一起。我听说你想给我讲一段移动人行道科幻小说。是的。所以有一点移动人行道历史我们没能完全放进报道里。这是一个来自40年代的短篇小说，实际上是关于作为城市交通工具的移动人行道版本。作者是罗伯特·海因莱因。
moving walkways are doomed because they're archaic or slow or take up too much space, for me, something else remains true, which is that they rock. They're joyful machines that just for a minute, absorb you into the symphony of moving parts that is our modern world. If you look back at all the moving walkways that were successful throughout history, they succeeded in large part not because they were efficient, but because people genuinely enjoyed riding them. So even if I lose 30 seconds taking the moving walkway, you're gonna see me on that thing, standing on the right to let the other passengers go by.
好的。嗯，我喜欢他的书。我不确定他的政治立场，但我喜欢他的书。好的，其实你说这个很有趣，因为我们很快就会谈到这一点。好的。但我们谈论他是因为他写了这个短篇小说，名字叫《道路必须滚动》。哦，太棒了。是的。
all right this is the final moving walkway of the journey and I've stepped on the baggage attendants are definitely laughing at me but that's okay because I'm having a great time so I'm laughing to you the moving walkway is now ending please look down coming up after the break we've got some moving walkway science fiction Okay, we are back, and I'm with Jasper Davidoff, who reported that story. And I hear you want to tell me about a piece of Moving Walkway Science Fiction. Yes. So there was this little bit of Moving Walkway history that we couldn't quite fit into the piece. And it's this short story from the 1940s that is actually about a version of moving walkways that do serve as urban transit. And it's by the author Robert Heinlein.
那是一个很棒的标题。这确实是一个非常扎实的标题。这个故事实际上被改编成了广播剧，所以我想给你带一小段。这是妈妈，看他们跑，抓紧。永远不要为我们的道路滚动而做，为什么你骑，为什么你骑，我们正在向下看，所以你的道路在滚动，哦，它很高，很高，这真是真正的思维剧场广播。它非常令人回味。所以《道路必须滚动》的内容是，它本质上是在美国创造了这个反乌托邦，设置在
Okay. Well, I like his book. I'm unsure about his politics, but I like his books. Okay, well, it's actually funny that you say that because we will get to that very much. Okay. But we were talking about him because he wrote this short story, and it is called The Roads Must Roll. Oh, excellent. Yeah.
未来的一个版本，城市被州际公路的主导地位撕裂，汽车交通太多，没人能去任何地方，每个人的生活都被毁了。不可能。是的，谁能想象这个版本的美国？谁能想象这样一个世界？嗯，你知道，在1940年，这还不是美国最终会达到的那种“汽车大脑”混乱的程度。
That's an amazing title. It is a really solid title. And this story was actually turned into a radio play, so I wanted to bring you a little snippet of that. Here's a mom, watch them run, hold on. never done for our roadways go rolling along why you ride why you ride we are watching down inside so your roadways be rolling along oh it's high high he's some real theater of the mind radio right there it's it's very evocative so the deal with the roads must roll is that it's essentially creating this dystopia set here in the u.s. in a
所以海因莱因在这里有点先见之明。但在他的版本中，社会没有向汽车的霸权低头，而是转向了移动人行道的增压版本来到达任何地方。然后工程师们接管了。他们禁止了汽车，拆除了超级公路，取而代之的是建造了滚动道路，机械化的道路像巨大的传送带一样移动，
version of the future where cities have been torn apart by, you know, the dominance of interstate highways and there's so much automobile traffic that no one can get anywhere and everyone's lives are ruined. Impossible. Yeah, who could imagine this version of the U.S.? Who can imagine such a world? Well, you know, in 1940, this was not quite the level of car brains chaos that the U.S. would eventually reach.
在巨大的转子上以每小时5到100英里的速度旋转，将货物、食物和人从一个城市运送到另一个城市，从海岸运送到海岸。这非常戏剧性。每小时100英里。这是一个非常快速的移动人行道。那么你从这个故事中感觉到海因莱因是否接触过当时真实移动人行道的实际技术发展吗？嗯，这很有趣。
so Heinlein's being a little bit prescient here. But in his version, instead of bowing down to the supremacy of the car, the Society in the Roads Must Roll essentially turns to a supercharged version of the moving walkway to get everywhere. Then the engineers took over. They banned the automobiles, tore up the superhighways, and in their place they built the rolling roads, mechanized roads that moved like huge conveyor belts,
我有一种感觉，他读过一点，因为他的移动道路的结构与阿尔弗雷德·斯皮尔的有点相似，也就是说，它们使用了一系列速度递增的平行路径。所以你走上外侧的那条，它比较慢，然后过渡到里面，你向内走，速度越来越快。还有一件有趣的事是，就像斯皮尔认为会散布在百老汇路线上的休息室和客厅一样，海因莱因把这些餐馆和商店直接放在了那个每小时100英里的中央快车道上。所以他的愿景是，你知道，你上去，开始真正飞速前往你要去的地方。
whirling along on their giant rotors at speeds ranging from 5 to 100, miles an hour, carrying the freight, the food, and the people from city to city and coast to coast. This is very dramatic. 100 miles per hour. It's a very fast moving walkway. So do you get a sense from this story that Heinlein was in touch with the actual technological developments of real moving walkways around this time? Well, it's interesting.
它们在巨大的转子上旋转，速度从每小时5英里到100英里不等，将货物、食物和人员从一个城市运送到另一个城市，从一个海岸运送到另一个海岸。这非常引人注目。每小时100英里。这就像一条移动速度非常快的步行道。那么，从这个故事中，你是否感觉到海因莱因了解当时现实中移动步行道的实际技术发展情况？嗯，这很有趣。
I kind of get the sense that he had read up a little bit because his moving roads are structured in kind of a similar way to Alfred Spears, which is to say they use this series of parallel paths that increase in speed. So you get on the outer one and it's slower and that transitions you, you work your way inward and you get faster and faster. And the other thing that's funny is that, like, in a similar way to these lounges and drawing rooms that Speer thought would be scattered along the route on Broadway, Heinlein places these restaurants and stores directly atop that Central Express kind of 100-mile-an-hour lane. And so his vision is, you know, you get on there, you start really rocketing to wherever you're going,
我有一种感觉，他确实做了一些研究，因为他的移动道路结构与阿尔弗雷德·斯皮尔的设计有相似之处，也就是说，它们使用了一系列速度递增的平行路径。你先踏上最外层，速度较慢，然后过渡到内层，越往里走速度就越快。还有一件有趣的事是，就像斯皮尔设想的那些散布在百老汇沿线的休息室和客厅一样，海因莱因也将餐馆和商店直接安置在那种时速100英里的中央快车道上。所以他的愿景是，你知道，你踏上去，就开始飞速前往你要去的地方。
and you can, like, hang out and kick back and grab a snack or something while you're doing that. That's right. It's like grabbing a snack from the cart on the bullet train in Japan. Yes. No, that's actually a very astute connection. There's actually a character in the story who's visiting the city. And he's like, wow, this really feels like, you know, grabbing dinner on a train. So where's the dystopia? Like, this sounds, you know, okay with me. It does sound good. Unfortunately, some very bad things happen in the roads must roll.
你可以一边做这些事，一边闲逛、放松，顺便买点零食吃。没错。就像在日本新干线的餐车上买零食一样。是的。不，这其实是一个非常敏锐的联想。故事里确实有一个角色去那个城市参观。他说，哇，这感觉真的就像在火车上吃晚餐一样。那么反乌托邦在哪里呢？听起来对我来说还不错。听起来确实不错。遗憾的是，在《道路必须滚动》中发生了一些非常糟糕的事情。
Some people end up dying because of this conflict between the working engineers that keep the roads running and the government that kind of governs them. And so the real question that animates this story is how the power to keep the roads moving and keep society moving is centralized. Because the idea here is that the roads have become a completely essential. non-negotiable service. It has to work at all costs or, you know, everything will be snarled up and stop working. And so sort of the protagonist, who's the head of the Sacramento sector of the roads, talks about how the engineers are actually indoctrinated into this military-like style of hierarchy. They're not allowed to strike. There's no grievances. There's no real critical thinking allowed even. And so as part of that, the song that you heard earlier, the anthem of
有些人因为负责维护道路运行的工程师与管理他们的政府之间的冲突而丧生。因此，推动这个故事的核心问题是，保持道路畅通和社会运转的权力是如何被集中的。因为这里的理念是，道路已经成为一种绝对必要、不可协商的服务。它必须不惜一切代价运行，否则一切都会陷入混乱并停止运转。所以，作为萨克拉门托道路部门负责人的主角谈到，工程师们实际上被灌输了一种类似军事风格的等级制度。他们不允许罢工。没有申诉渠道。甚至不允许有真正的批判性思维。因此，作为其中的一部分，你之前听到的那首歌，也就是
the engineers is actually adapted from the official song, of the U.S. Army, which is the Army goes rolling along. Yeah, yeah. I'm starting to feel the hind line in all of this. I mean, it's ironic to me to sort of put the idea of the moving walkway into the hands of, like, oppressive state control because all the history that, you know, we talked about in the last section, the moving walkway is kind of this whimsical, futuristic, world's fair, you know, getting people over the Brooklyn Bridge and this fun way and this Lucille Ball in her high. high heels. It is not like oppressive state control. No. And it's interesting because there is this theme of how at least one author thought about moving walkways in the 40s, but supporters, even at that point, still saw them very differently. They said these machines are really going to enable
工程师们的颂歌，实际上改编自美国陆军的官方歌曲《陆军在前进》。是的，是的。我开始感觉到这一切背后的阴影了。我的意思是，对我来说，把自动人行道的想法交给压迫性的国家控制，这很讽刺，因为我们上一节谈到的所有历史中，自动人行道是一种异想天开、充满未来感、世界博览会式的存在，比如让人们以这种有趣的方式穿过布鲁克林大桥，还有露西尔·鲍尔穿着高跟鞋走在上面。这根本不像压迫性的国家控制。不。有趣的是，至少有一位作者在40年代思考过自动人行道，但即使在那个时候，支持者们对它们的看法也截然不同。他们说这些机器真的会带来
freedom. You can get on and off wherever you want. You'll be able to move wherever in the city you want to go. And actually, I should say we don't quite get to this in the story, but there is still kind of a group of people who believes this, they really still want to create this futuristic vision of a moving walkway as a mass transit solution, one that could really actually take you somewhere at 10 miles an hour. I can't believe people are still working on this. Yes, they very much are. And so the modern version of this speedy goal is called the accelerated moving walkway, and probably
自由。你想在哪里上下车都可以。你将能够去城市里的任何地方。事实上，我应该说，我们在故事中并没有完全讲到这一点，但仍然有一群人相信这一点，他们真的仍然想创造这种自动人行道的未来愿景，作为一种大众交通解决方案，一种真正能以每小时10英里的速度带你去某处的东西。我不敢相信人们还在研究这个。是的，他们确实在研究。所以，这种高速目标的现代版本被称为加速自动人行道，可能
the most famous version of these was actually installed in 2003. at the Montparnasse metro station in Paris. So the situation there was riders had to basically make this 600-foot trek to get between metro lines, which is a pretty long transfer. And so at one point, the metro had conventional moving walkways there.
最著名的版本实际上是在2003年安装在巴黎蒙帕纳斯地铁站的。当时的情况是，乘客基本上必须走600英尺的距离才能在地铁线路之间换乘，这是一个相当长的换乘距离。所以有一次，地铁在那里安装了传统的自动人行道。
They moved under two miles an hour, and that took almost four minutes from end to end. And so the transit agency decided to try and speed things up and create what they called a trotterr-r-roulon-rapid, where you would have to basically step, over these zones and get increasingly faster until you ultimately were moving at seven and a half miles an hour, which is a real clip. But as you might expect, people were not very good at doing this,
它们的速度不到每小时两英里，从头到尾几乎需要四分钟。因此，交通部门决定尝试加快速度，创造出他们所谓的“快速步行道”，你基本上必须跨过这些区域，速度越来越快，直到最终以每小时7.5英里的速度移动，这速度相当快。但正如你所料，人们并不擅长这样做，
following the instructions to hold on and go through sort of that transition zone. And also just like not everyone has the greatest sense of balance, which is a design factor that you definitely need to consider in this kind of thing. So a lot of trips and falls and almost immediately they had to cut the speed and it went down to six miles an hour and people kept tripping and falling because that's still really fast. And so before the decade was out, they decommissioned this faster walkway and brought back the conventional ones. It totally makes sense to me that it wouldn't work at all. I just know of a few people, many of them are my kids, who would still love a 10 mile an hour conveyor belt. Like they would do very well with that. No, exactly. I mean like it is,
无法遵循抓好扶手并穿过那种过渡区的指示。而且并不是每个人都有最好的平衡感，这是你在这种设计中绝对需要考虑的因素。所以很多人绊倒和摔倒，几乎立刻他们就不得不降低速度，降到了每小时6英里，但人们还是不断绊倒和摔倒，因为那仍然非常快。所以在那十年结束之前，他们拆除了这条更快的步行道，换回了传统的步行道。我完全理解为什么它根本行不通。我只认识几个人，其中很多是我的孩子，他们仍然会喜欢每小时10英里的传送带。他们会适应得很好。不，没错。我的意思是，这
very much a thing that you would like to experience in the world someday, even if it's like not something you're taking every day to get to the train. But I do have good news for your kids and anyone else who has this fantasy, which is that it's still possible. There is specifically a Cincinnati-based startup called Beltways, and these guys claim they are finally going to hit the 10 mile an hour mark. That's one small step for man and one fast leap for mankind. We think of them as little Lego pieces and they connect together to form a walkway of any length. And then section by section, we accelerate the passenger. Accelerate them up to 10 miles per hour. I mean, it's amazing to me. The whole pitch sounds exactly like Alfred Spear. It's just like
确实是你有一天想在世界上体验的东西，即使它不是你每天坐火车时会用到的东西。但我对你的孩子和任何有这种幻想的人有个好消息，那就是它仍然是有可能的。具体来说，有一家位于辛辛那提的初创公司叫Beltways，这些人声称他们终于要达到每小时10英里的速度了。这是个人的一小步，却是人类的一大步。我们把它们看作小乐高积木，它们连接在一起形成任意长度的步行道。然后分段加速乘客。将他们加速到每小时10英里。我的意思是，这让我感到惊讶。整个推销词听起来和阿尔弗雷德·斯皮尔的一模一样。就像
130 years later. It does. We just try to keep doing this thing over and over again. I mean, it just, it fascinates me that this idea will never die. And it also fascinates me that it'll always be futuristic. Like, it never stops feeling futuristic that it felt futuristic in 1900 and it feels futuristic in 2025. That's kind of an amazing quality. I mean, it's interesting
130年后一样。确实。我们只是不断地重复做这件事。我的意思是，这个想法永远不会消亡，这让我着迷。而且它永远看起来都很“未来感”，这也让我着迷。它在1900年感觉很未来，在2025年也感觉很未来，它从未停止过那种未来感。这真是一种神奇的特质。我的意思是，这很有趣，
because you think about how advanced they thought this idea was back in the 1870s, and then 70 years later, it still felt futuristic to have something under your feet that could move. And even now,
因为你想到他们在1870年代认为这个想法有多先进，然后70年后，脚下能移动的东西仍然感觉很未来。即使是现在，
it still feels like this amazing technological leap. I will say of Beltways, They do say they have a partnership with the Cincinnati airport, and they would like to get one of these cooking in there pretty soon. So we will definitely have to keep an eye on that and see if someday there will be a 10-mile-an-hour conveyor belt for 99-PI listeners to go check out. But, you know, maybe this one does. Maybe it doesn't. It feels like no matter what happens, these moving walkway moonshots will just, you know, continue inevitably cycling around over and over and over again, which is sort of a conveyor belt. I know. That's right. Exactly. The metaphor of like it being always out of reach, like we're always walking towards the goal of a fast, you know, moving walkway. And it never gets any closer. It's kind of like walking on her own treadmill.
它仍然感觉像是一次惊人的技术飞跃。我得说，关于Beltways，他们确实说他们与辛辛那提机场有合作关系，他们希望很快就能在那里投入使用。所以我们肯定得密切关注，看看有一天是否真的会有每小时10英里的传送带供99PI的听众去体验。但是，你知道，也许这个能成。也许不能。感觉无论发生什么，这些自动人行道的“登月计划”都将不可避免地一遍又一遍地循环往复，这本身就像一条传送带。我知道。没错。正是如此。那种总是遥不可及的隐喻，就像我们总是朝着快速自动人行道的目标走去。却永远无法靠近。这有点像在跑步机上行走。
Well, this is really fun stuff, Jasper. Thanks so much for the story. And thanks for talking with me. Yeah. It's my pleasure. Bolt was produced this week by Jasper Davidoff and edited by Emmett Fitzgerald. Mixed by Martine Gonzalez, music by Swan Real. Special thanks this week to Madeline Brozen, Paul Collins, Ricardo Scorinci, William Spruill, and Andrew Sparberg. Our executive producer is Kathy 2. Delaney Hall is our senior editor, Kirk Colestate is the digital director. The rest of the team includes Chris Barubei, Jason DeLeon, Joe Rosenberg, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Lay, Lachamadon, Kelly Prime, Jacob Medina Gleason, Talon and Rain
好吧，这真的很有趣，贾斯珀。非常感谢你带来的故事。也谢谢你和我交谈。是的。这是我的荣幸。本周的《Bolt》由贾斯珀·达维多夫制作，埃米特·菲茨杰拉德编辑。马丁·冈萨雷斯混音，斯旺·里尔配乐。本周特别感谢马德琳·布罗岑、保罗·柯林斯、里卡多·斯科林奇、威廉·斯普鲁尔和安德鲁·斯帕伯格。我们的执行制片人是凯西·2。德莱尼·霍尔是我们的高级编辑，柯克·科尔斯泰特是数字总监。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝、杰森·德里昂、乔·罗森伯格、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、薇薇安·莱、拉查马顿、凯利·普莱姆、雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森、塔隆和雷恩
Stradley and me, Roman Mars. The 99% visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Sirius XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north, in the Pandora Building, in beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us online on all the usual social media spaces as well as our own Discord server. There's a link to that, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. Thank you. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
斯特拉德利，还有我，罗曼·马斯。《99%无形》的标志是由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作的。我们是Sirius XM播客家族的一员，现在总部位于北边六个街区的潘多拉大厦，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在所有常见的社交媒体空间以及我们自己的Discord服务器上找到我们。那里有链接，以及《99PI》过去的所有剧集，网址是99PI.org。谢谢。谢谢。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。